so what are we going to talk about today
chris
change you know
my attitude has not been all that great
you know it's getting hotter
um
i got a job coming up so a lot of stuff
that i do like drugs i can't do no more
you know
so yeah like
i've been sober for like two days now
it's hard you know
i was doing it in prison i paroled
addicted to heroin
and crystal and now
i've been sober and it's my attitude's
not all that great and i'm learning how
to deal with it you know be productive
you know
so just to let people know that anybody
can get a job
just because you got a record on they
want parolees and probation they
don't matter what race you are you know
don't be scared to get a job and you
know
you know um
i try to talk to the youngsters they
don't even want to listen you know
everybody's on that fed and all [ __ ]
you're trying to change i'm trying to
turn my life around because i don't want
to do life you know
because i got a bad temper you know
and i like to pick up weapons
i threw all my weapons away i sold my
gun i had all that [ __ ]
i
i told all the connections don't sell me
nothing
when my uncle
threatened and you sell him something
he's gonna he's gonna kill him you know
who do you get your temper from um
i don't know my my mom from my mom's
side i got real quick
real fast i flash she used to call me
that
and when i get mad i go extremely
overboard and i get really violent
and i'm unpredictable anyway you know
i never set up a path you know now i
have to be you must have been scared now
i have to yeah swastika tattoos on your
face yeah
very ruthless very relentless with it
too
a very revengeful team you know
a lot of stuff i have to overlook like
oh he's a snitch he's that man [ __ ] all
that [ __ ] man
you know my my attitude i have to change
it's not easy you know
you know i got over the
institutionalized thing now the attitude
i heard
you're always going to have this not
i just have to find other avenues you
know i'm having a hard time but
i ain't been in i ain't been in the
county jail in two years
you know in two more months i'll be off
probation so
two more months i finally got off the
validation like two months ago so i'm
not getting validated anymore that was
so hard
the police don't they don't even they
just drive right past me
i had a big old knife last night that i
was giving away and the police just
man you really are crazy ain't you like
this big a big old machete i used to
carry under the sheet
i used to carry guns in my waistband i i
had two ottoman on hollywood boulevard
two sks's fully automatic
i sold all that [ __ ] give me an example
of how your temper would flare my temper
has got me the second strike
i [ __ ] uh down there beat a cop to
death
i just
jumped through his window
if he was at a red line i just jumped in
that's how that god got caught for
everything else for what reason because
he was a cop
and he messed with me for years and he
used to stop me he beat one of my
homeboys so he was ev-elected
he likes taking us
to areas to like the black area to
projects in east l.a hey this this white
boy's a rat and just drop us off at
three in the morning and you got to
figure out how are you going to get out
of it
or or he'll plant drugs on you when you
get in the station you'll end up with an
in-house possession which is a five
minute license a three and a half year
term in prison that's the kind of cop he
is a damn near killed him he's in a
wheelchair now he can't even walk
i beat him almost to death you did that
yeah
how much i regret it how much time you
get for that i ended up doing 20 years i
had too low i took i the feds wanted to
pick up my case you know
i i was facing like 75 years to life i
ended up with 20 years i took 20 years
with 85 percent it took me two lawyers
i spent like over two million dollars on
these lawyers just to retain them was
like
250 thou just to retain them
because you have to have um
capital punishment like
then i was fighting hate crime at first
too so i had that capital punishment
lawyers a lot of money you know
i'm trying to tell the
the viewers in the public these
youngsters man don't
don't try to be like me especially in
the valley don't try to be like me earn
no tattoos and be no gangster get a job
man you know
raise your kids i'm trying to be a
father you know
it's just
my attitude bro
stuff just this dumb [ __ ] just pisses me
off like walking here
they would they would everybody you
gonna sell me that phone right down the
street on the tent
what you looking at my tent they ain't
nobody looking in your oh you oh you
want them skin heads i've seen you on
youtube black down here and
yeah yeah they mention you hey yeah you
want to get your money joked too
like oh boy i said man [ __ ]
i just said whatever deal god bless you
and i walked over here bro because i
needed this money that bad you know
because i broke now all my money i paid
all my bills my credit card all
and my i had to give my mom a bunch of
older like two quiet two
grand
and i sent my daughter some money so you
know i'm gonna buy food with this money
tell me about your tattoos my tattoos
are like your remaining tattoos you had
a bunch removed right yeah i got i had
to earn stab people i uh i've got a
spider web which
which represents each riot you've been
in a viking
started wars in prison
you know it's just a lot of political
[ __ ] you know a tear drop
that's a verified kill of some two
people
i have to see you do it
you know and i have nightmares i regret
every one of these tattoos i earned
every tattoo on them and the other ones
i had to keep point and make sure they
didn't get busted tattooing on somebody
else and the tattoos on your chest this
this i had earned that's a hate crime
you know i faced it i faced a death
penalty for a year
that's lethal injection i
by fog damn
you know
and i took a rap for somebody else
you know
20 years i took really someone else
someone else was with me and did most of
that on that cop
you know
they just threw me on the bus
you know and pretty much [ __ ]
ratted me off at the same time my own
homeboy that i grew up with elementary
school my so-called homeboy homeboy
which ain't [ __ ] do you have any friends
from that life no
i don't even call them and i told them
don't bother me don't come by me don't
call them how do you get out how do you
get out how do you get out of that
you just
got to change everything you do the
people you talk to
you gotta you gotta talk you gotta hang
out and try to be friends with the races
that you ate
that's the only way
you have to learn to get along with
everything
you have to
just turn all the 360 that's the only
way would you call yourself a racist in
your past no i'm not a racist you know
i'm for my race still i'm not against
any race until they're racial with me
i don't call people call them out i
don't hate them never have
yeah i hate i hate to [ __ ]
i hate religious organized religion like
jewish orthodox i can't stand them
you know
that's what we're against them and the
church and the government that's what
we're again we're not against the blacks
that's nowhere we're not that's the
youngsters that do that and blast on the
jewish synagogue i'm a white supremacy
we don't do that we make the rules for
we enforce the 88 you can't you can't
follow lady precepts you get a tattoo
you just broke them all if you do drug
if you don't have a job
you can't follow if if if you go to jail
a real a real skinhead family like
hammer skins or something they don't
even get holly they don't they just
drink they don't even smoke weed or
cigarettes if you don't have a job
you can't you can't preserve your race
you can't
if you hit your wife
so it's all a bunch of [ __ ] you know
every race is for the race i'm still for
my race
i'm still a white supremacist who always
will be but i don't hate no other race
i hate organized [ __ ]
because the jews are more racial than
anybody
you know they can't stand me and to
mostly the blacks on the blonde hair
blue-eyed devil i go over there to
venice and stand in front of them on
purpose
i've been called words by better you
know
i just laugh at stuff now you know
because at the inside i want to kill a
lot of these people
i wanted to take that black dude's head
off down there
yeah when they make comments like hey
white boy let me get that phone hey you
know the dude down there you're going to
go see you want to get your money took
like he got his tool
i said man you ain't taking nothing here
bro but god bless you
i said you have to kill me because i
ain't giving you nothing though
and if you and you better hope i'm dead
yeah the comments like that that's what
triggers me other than that
i get along with all races i go to pro i
know i i eat i go to crips grapes three
watts i can go to jordan down projects
cause somebody's out i got a key to it
and eat with his family
but in the valley we're a little
different we get along with all races
and that's why they don't like me
because i don't care
you don't tell me what to do i've done
put in too much work
i i tell them unless you've done more
than i have then you can tell me
something other than that shut up
i told people just stay away from me man
with that negative [ __ ] i just say
god bless you and i don't even believe
in god but i say it anyway just
that shuts them up i said i'm out of
here i got to go get some money i got
time to argue with you
i said but if you i told the black dude
if you ever want to do something we can
fight though but other than that get
back go back in the tent he was about i
should let my dog out go ahead
and i'll just get bit you know
there he's bracelet
see feel the skin that haunts me
i'm not i'm not with a lot of that i'm
not active anymore but
they know i'm a skinhead
a lot of them watch that stuff i'm sure
everybody all these kids don't watch
that thing they know who i am they all
because of the youngsters
they have blasts on the wall and the kkk
so they think skinheads are the same way
i'm not a skinhead i'm a white
supremacist there's a difference they
don't know
that i'm not causing problems for no one
man
actually them kids if i catch a kid
blasting that [ __ ] on the church i'm
gonna beat the hell out of them you know
because that's not what we do
we're supposed to preserve our race and
take care of our family for our family
to keep
whites with whites i'm not with
interracial marriage and all that [ __ ]
but it is what it is you why do you not
approve of interracial relationships
well i just don't that's my personal
opinion you know yeah but what's what's
behind that i just
it's just
something that's in me you know
now i'm learning to accept it you know
were you taught that as a child yeah i'm
learning to accept it and you know
that's just how
this generation is that's how it is
that's reality now what i mean how do
you feel about blacks and whites
having relationships now
that
is what it is you know love is love if
they love each other i'm for it but
you know i'm learning to deal with it
you know
there's love is love you know
i've learned of
the colors the skin don't mean nothing
to me no more you know i'm over it it's
it was all it just got me a bunch of
time and [ __ ] my attitude up that's
what it did
it's not that's not real
that's came from the devil you know
pretty much it's man-made [ __ ]
there's no supreme race there's none of
that you're supposed to be for your race
blacks are for the race
if you got mexican mother for the race
the pisces are for their race
he's supposed to be you know i'm not
racial against no one bro
i think
you know there's some things i don't
accept that's my personal belief in the
opinion
right
everybody's entitled to their opinion i
know some people won't like because i
don't accept it but
hey i'm learning to you know does your
daughter have a boyfriend
yeah
they seem to love each other he takes
care of himself that's all that i want
him to take care of her
he's black he takes care of her he says
he loves her i go by his word i said as
long as he takes care of her she gets
she don't have to do nothing and he has
a job
and she takes care of
my granddaughter
and she has a part-time job and
she looks good she they got a nice house
and hey that's all that matters to me
that he loves her and takes care of him
and doesn't put his hands on her don't
call her out her name i don't know i'm
cool i'm learning to agree and accept
that too you know
i'm getting older you know you either
get wiser or you stay dumb and ignorant
and
i know what life i'm bad at that's what
that attitude is going to get anybody
you're mellowing with age
you're mellowing as you age 53 you know
i'll be 54 march 7th which is another
couple of weeks
what another week and a half a week
now that's coming up it's what the 31st
first is tomorrow
versus yesterday huh yesterday well i
got like four five more days six yeah
i'll be 54. you know
i'm the only one that's done three
interviews huh
there's been a few people that have done
a few yeah you know that marry many of
it tell me about your dad
i didn't know him never knew yeah he
left my mom when she was pregnant and i
guess he was in fort bragg air force
base fort bragg california i was born on
an air force base i've never known him
he died when i went to prison so i don't
know who he is
i know his name was steve
steven kemp and that's all i know
never met him i didn't have a father
every boyfriend my mom had beat on her
so
i was my own father i think i did a
pretty good job you know i went to jail
but a lot of people listen to me
you know
a lot of females come to me he's been
raped and i listen to him
i know how to
talk to blacks in every race because
being in prison i learn how to be
political you got to know how to talk
you know
i get along with everybody a lot of
blacks like me you know i'm not racial
against blacks but blacks have had our
back in the county in prison more than
any other ring
we never
i've been in one riot against them and
that's just had to have to happen you
know but
you know i hate most of my race i can't
stand them who
i'm one of the people i really don't
like anybody really you know
i don't even like myself at the time but
you know i'm learning to accept a lot of
stuff
and agree with it you know i just and if
i don't like it hey
obviously you don't have nothing good to
say don't say nothing at all keep keep
it to yourself man i just
avoid
that person and go around it i got a job
you know
yeah i was talking to mine somebody so i
got to keep my mouth shut and i'm going
to be told what to do is i'm not their
boss
if i don't then i'm going to get fired
if you had your life to live all over
again what would you have done
differently
i tried to forget when my daughter was
born i would try not to do drugs and
maybe have a relative real job how far
did you want school
i got a ged in high school and uh yeah
but i had a couple of jobs when i got
out i worked at a [ __ ] uh restaurant
a couple of times yeah but as as a
student in school how far did you go
oh just a ged and and juvenile all
that's it nobody like and did you go to
high school
no
high school gd's equivalent to high
school yeah
no i didn't no
i dropped out in junior high yeah
yeah
i was quite going to school and i was
like nine years old
yeah yeah i was at home i had to cook
for myself my mom was too busy
[Music]
you know i learned how to cook when i
was like seven
changed my brother and sister's diapers
all that cleaned the house
walk them to i walked into school and
then went back home
went into school snuck out of school
and they called my mom and she
she never came to any of the meetings
when i was expelled or held after school
because i never went
it kicked me out of any school i went to
i got kicked out anyway
i used to throw stuff at the teachers
and all that [ __ ] i didn't
don't like to be told what to do what do
you credit most for where your life
what do i cry
is it your parents or the environment
you grew up in or your friends when do i
what what would you blame for the
i'm a product of my environment the
people that i put myself allow myself to
be around
what i've seen product of my environment
you know
i was a dumb ass and
they sold me a dream and i thought all
that was loyalty and respect to your
race was
none of them bought me a lawyer none of
that
i gave you one package that don't mean
[ __ ]
it's about money
loyalty don't mean [ __ ]
nobody gives a [ __ ]
you get gunned down they don't give a
[ __ ] about you
kids are
killing their own moms beating their
moms up
every
race this is rough it's this this this
day and age is super violent everywhere
that fedenal is everywhere and
everybody's
it's getting really violent it's the end
of the days end times you know you could
tell
it's on the news we're about to go on a
nuclear war pretty soon it seems like
you know
i'm just trying to get that job i got
three more weeks i'll have a job
making 27 an hour starting
you feel yeah it's a [ __ ] it's a
union job so it's hard to get fired
yeah
but they they drug test so i'll be drug
test as long as i pass that
stay in the right track i have to quit
drugs stay on the right track i don't
know i've never been sober
for no three days of my life really not
even in jail i got high every day so you
got a challenge ahead of you huh you got
a challenge ahead of you yeah i've been
sober for three days now
i to get food
and and some diapers and [ __ ] from my
grandmother all right let me help you
with that thank you
chris like nothing else no that's good
all right you're always interesting man
yeah good luck with john yeah thank you
man oh yeah
you